the rally began peacefully with the
streets of Barcelona awash in a sea of
protesters from the waterfront to the
city's landmark Sagrada família church
many carried catalan flags and banners
branded with slogans such as sit and
talk and freedom for political prisoners
pro-independence groups had called for a
peaceful march to demand the release of
nine separatist leaders found guilty of
sedition they were imprisoned by the
Supreme Court on October 14th the move
triggered a wave of anti Madrid
demonstrations some marred by heavy
violence spain's main parties have
consistently rejected any moves towards
Catalan independence protesters accused
Madrid of criminalizing dissent
Plus that it's time for the state to
find a solution because it seems that
this has no end and we're always at the
same point we've come here because we
are fed up but so much repression that
we have suffered from the state the
government in Madrid doesn't want to
listen to us or sit down and talk which
is what we want we have always defended
non-violence what is happening in
Barcelona is not a reflection of us we
separatists are not violent we want our
country we want to be free but when
night fell violence flared up again
[Applause]
several hundred protesters surrounded
police headquarters hurling bottles
paintballs and other objects at officers
in riot gear police backed by riot vans
charged the demonstrators to disperse
them all right let's bring in journalist
Steven burgeon he joins us now from
Barcelona hello to you Steven now the
vast majority of Catalan
pro-independence supporters were
peaceful we saw those numbers at the
rally
what exactly happened to spark that
violence and who was behind it apart
from a couple of days of quiet that
we've had as what's happened from the
start is we have a peaceful
demonstration of a very large number of
people and then as it disperses smaller
and organized groups who are despite
what your person in the interview said
our pro-independence and the majority
then set off usually to the headquarters
of the police which is where they were
last night the Spanish police and staged
a demonstrate demonstration and start
throwing things at the police and
taunting them and so on and last night
was a particularly large number of about
10,000 people outside the headquarters
and
when you can see in your video what
happened now later today we're going to
see anti separatist rallies what can we
expect there well probably I'm not sure
how larger be there was a couple of
years ago there was one that was nearly
a million people there this is supported
by most of the main national political
parties not the Catalan regional parties
and various other non political groups
the what we'll see is you know these are
people who are against separation from
Spain unfortunately they tend to the
people who make the most noise on this
particular March tend to be Spanish
nationalists so we have Catalan
nationalists on the one hand and Spanish
Nationals on the other whereas there are
a lot of people in the middle who you
know don't basically don't want to wave
either flag well with Spain being so
divided do you see any path forward for
the independence movement at this point
[Music]
not at the moment because certainly not
before November 10th when there is a
general election and you know Catalonia
is as part of campaigning fodder for the
election after that first of all we have
to see who wins and that is very open to
questing at the moment and if the
socialist leader whether oh Sanchez can
form a government then I imagine that he
will attempt to start some talks if on
the other hand and this is increasingly
likely there's a right-wing coalition
they will not even consider how he talks
about independence because they regard
the
Spain as a you know the entirety of
Spain as a state as something in
virtually sacred and they wouldn't
countenance Faden starting totes
alright journalist Steven virgin in
Barcelona thank you very much thank you